- I'm back with Billy Gardell!
Give it up for him!
(audience cheers)
His show is called "Bob Hearts Abishola".
You can watch it on
CBS and CBS All Access.
Say it five times fast,
Abishola, Abishola, Abishola.
I'm gonna nail it by the end of the show.
My next guest was named the Los Angeles
Unified School District in L.A County
2020-2021 Teacher Of The Year.
That's a title, y'all, she dominates.
Please welcome Mrs.
Rhiannon Chavez, give it up!
(audience cheers)
Meet Billy, first of all.
- Hi Billy.
- Hi, it's a pleasure to meet you,
and thank you for what you do.
- Thank you, nice to meet you.
- I mean, his teacher
is amazing, we love him.
So what do you teach?
What's your like specialty?
What do you do?
- I teach fourth grade at
186th Street Elementary School
in Gardena.
- Yes.
- I am an ELD teacher, which means
I teach English language learners.
So I've had students from
Cameroon speak French,
from Brazil speaking Portuguese,
from Egypt speaking Arabic.
So as you can imagine,
my classroom is filled
with culture, language,
love, and lots of learning.
- Wow.
- But you know what?
They come in with so much already,
especially with their language,
and talking with all the
kids on the playground,
they pick up on a lot of language.
- That's the ones you don't want, yes.
- So why did you want to become a teacher?
I loved school and everything
about it when I was little,
and I had great teachers, but
I never saw myself in them.
Nobody looked like me.
So when I became a teacher's
assistant for a middle school,
a lot of the young girls,
they would look up to me and admire me.
And they say, you're going to college?
You traveled where over the weekend?
And so I really felt that I could inspire
little girls that look
like me in my community.
So I said, I'm gonna be a teacher.
- Representation.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's very important.
- Yes, so I'm doing what I love.
And it's a passion in my heart.
And I think with teaching,
it always is that passion.
- You have to have passion.
I have watched my mom in
a classroom and I'm like,
whoa the patience of
Job, that one. (laughs)
- Can't learn it in a
book, that's for sure.
- Oh my gosh.
And you have to be so patient and calm.
- But sometimes they get
a little chatty, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Oh, you know
what, we are the same human.
- And in my toolbox, I
have the teacher look.
Every teacher has the teacher look.
So that saves me a couple of
times during our Zoom sessions.
- Yes, see, I grew up with
a teacher for a mother.
So this was the same look was like
oh my God, I'm in so much trouble.
Like it was the same
look, can you show us?
I have to ask you,
what's your teacher look?
Oh, God, see?
Oh, the slow blink, the slow
blink, that was amazing!
- I'll wait.
- I'll wait. (laughs)
- There's the look.
- Oh god, I love the
slow blink, I love it.
We're basically sweating,
Billy and I, 'cause we,
I don't know, I'm a part of this show,
I don't know why I did this to myself.
I have not seen these questions,
but apparently there is
a fourth grade pop quiz
that you are gonna give me and Billy.
- Oh, yes.
- Okay, let's not judge, I
just wanna lead with that
because we all have our strengths,
and we all have our weaknesses.
- Can we just be a team,
instead of two people?
- No, I'm gonna kill you!
- I need a lifeline.
- Okay, we'll each answer one at a time.
And if we don't know
the answer or are wrong,
the other person can have a guess.
So if I get more correct the right side
of the audience gets a prize.
And if Billy gets more
correct, no pressure Billy,
but the left side will get a prize.
I feel like I'm at the chalkboard
and I'm having to do math.
Oh, okay.
- Question number one.
- Okay, Billy, you can have the first one.
- Billy, question number one,
category, social studies.
What are the three branches of government?
- Legislative, Judicial,
and I don't know what the word for it is.
- It's legislative, it's judicial,
and it is the president's, right?
- The real term is executive.
- Executive, whatever executive.
But that's the part that
was the presidents, right?
- Technically, yes.
- I say technically it's okay.
- Question number two,
category, language arts.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- What punctuation goes
before a conjunction?
- Before a conjunction?
♪ Conjunction junction,
what's your function ♪
Is it like, you mean the apos-
Like when you do cannot, you make can't?
Like a apostrophe, is that what you mean?
- A comma, comma conjunction.
- Oh my God no, I thought it was,
that's not even anywhere near right?
Like can and not, and can't what is that?
- I think you're thinking
of a contraction.
- A contraction!
I'm thinking of a contraction.
You know what?
Oh, this is gonna be bad.
- Thank God you can sing
and I can tell jokes.
- I know man.
- And I can correct your papers.
Last question category is science.
What is the smallest planet?
- Wait, this is a trick, this is a trick.
We're gonna go together on this one.
'Cause Pluto used to
be the smallest plate.
But now it's like a dwarf planet.
- Yeah, I don't know why we,
I'm not sure why we cut
Pluto out of the club.
It was a standard when I was growing up.
I don't know what it did wrong.
- Me too, brother.
And then now it's like a dwarf,
and I don't know if they're counting it.
This could be a trick question.
- Yeah, I would say if
we're counting Pluto in,
it might be Pluto, but if
we're not counting Pluto in,
I would say Mercury.
(bell dings)
- Good job!
Wait, which one was right?
Are you counting Pluto?
- We don't count Pluto anymore.
- This is my thing, can
we talk about new math?
'Cause here's my thing.
Like all of a sudden
my niece and my nephew,
'cause I got little toddlers,
like, so they're not there yet.
Like, there's some kind
of math, common core math,
and it's like two plus
two could equal five.
That's some BS.
Okay, the winner is
Billy 'cause I'm a loser.
I love that my whole life I thought
Conjunction Junction was just about,
I don't know, it was a
contraction, it's fine.
But because everyone in
our house seats today
is a hardworking teacher,
you're definitely all winners.
So we're gifting everyone
$100 credit to Gilt.
At Gilt you can get insider access
to designer brands at unbelievable prices.
They have great new sales every day
in apparel, accessories, home and beauty.
Enjoy y'all.
Thank you so much, Mrs. Chavez,
for embarrassing me on television.
- You're fine, you're fine.
- And thank you so much for playing Billy.
I know you've got to run,
so I'll see you later, man, all right?
- Nice meeting you, and
have a great day you guys.
Thank you for having me.
- You too, man, have a blessed one.
All right, y'all can see
"Bob Heart's Abishola"
on CBS and CBS All Access.